[Music]
various paralyzed aah
I think biggest real life is actually
not doing enough well I just attended
the day didn't that you didn't do what
you're supposed to do or yeah I think
that's the baby I mean that's - for sure
but I feel like the biggest fear that I
have every day is who
nestle nobody liking me that's the UM I
think my biggest fear is dying and not
[Music]
running out of time
[Music]
is it laying in fertility Oh probably
not succeeding and like living on the
streets okay do you have something
specific that you want to commune just
be able to have a steady lifestyle just
be able to provide support myself and
then eventually who comes with me then
as well I guess not living each day like
I am Alive I am what's your biggest fear
in life Trump
El Torito Miyagi for some we complement
the heck I'm only advice vbe cigarette
syllable what's your biggest fear in
life that you're a cop now really ah to
be happy you want to be unhappy they get
scaring line is right out there actually
I am terribly afraid of shark
that
not having enough venture now having
enough adventure adventure yeah the
adventure and change I think I'll ask
elastic elasticity being able to be
flexible with everything
planning too much into spontaneous of
fun in the middle I get away to go not
doing that I feel like you to spill
everything my biggest fear in life is
losing my hair before I meet anyone
it has to be anything anything sighs
better you know ignorant people dying I
would say dying I think that's probably
the only thing I'm kind of scared of my
biggest fear in life is not succeeding
dying alone biggest fear in life failing
falling down stairs and you're not able
to see the bottom being misunderstood my
biggest fear in life being broke that
would suck like financially and like
emotionally and like
spiritually you know saying I want to be
like I want to be rich in life ah
now confer gives very to the calculating
Vaughn has unity
losing touch with
blood cells
my biggest fear is my love dying not my
biggest fear
[Music]
is worrying about my family Oh dine
alone I guess this is this got real
quick hey my biggest fear in life is not
living up to my full potential or not
really knowing your full work
I'm just not living the way I want to I
think being forced into live in a way I
don't want to for economic or political
reasons or something like that just not
being tricked
I don't have one no no
[Music]
you
[Music]